This universe is finite.
Its resource is finite.
If life is left unchecked.
Life will cease to exist.
That's Thanos, the Marvel super
villain who kills half of all
humanity with the snap of
his fingers in Avengers Infinity
War. As Marion Tupy and Gail Pooley
argue in their new book,
Superabundance.
Thanos is channeling millennia
old critiques of progress and
population growth.
He's also flat out wrong.
The past 200 years have seen
historically huge increases in
the number of people living on
planet Earth.
In 1800, there were 1 billion
people.
Now there are 8 billion.
We are flourishing more than ever
before and living longer,
more productive lives.
Tupy and Pooley chart how the real
prices of our most basic necessities
and virtually all luxuries
have declined over time.
And how free markets and human
innovation mean that our planet
is infinitely bountiful.
Gail Pooley, Marion Tupy.
Thanks for talkin to Reason.
My pleasure.
Glad to be here.
All right. So let's start
with the elevator pitch for
superabundance,
the story of population growth,
innovation and human flourishing on
an infinitely bountiful
planet.
Marian, why don't you start?
What's what's the elevator pitch for
this book?
Well, people have been wondering
about the relationship between
resource abundance and population
growth for at least two and a half
thousand years. The ancient
Egyptians saw it.
The ancient Greeks thought about it,
the ancient Romans thought about it,
the Chinese thought about it, the
Indians thought about it.
And really,
people have always had this sort of
ambiguous feeling about population
growth. But, 200 years ago
and really over the last 200 years,
specifically since Thomas Malthus
published his famous essay on the
principle of population, most
people have been generally
negative to to our population
growth. In other words, there was an
expectation that as population grew,
resources would become more
expensive, therefore scarcer, and
there would be some kind of calamity
maybe running out of food, the
starvation, so the world would
be would be destroyed as we
know it. Now, in the last 200
years, specifically between 1820
and 2022,
population of the world has
increased from 1 billion people
to 8 billion people.
And yet what we found
in our book, by looking at hundreds
of different commodities fuels,
minerals, metals, even
finished goods and some services,
everything has become cheaper
in terms of time price.
People simply have to work less
and less time in order to
buy things which
which are essential goods and
commodities. In order to survive.
Things are just getting cheaper.
And that tells us that
every human being on average creates
more value than he or she consumes.
That human beings are inventors
and innovators, and they
can create more value
forever, thereby increasing
standards of living.
And that is I mean, we'll get into
this, but you guys spend a lot of
time documenting the great
enrichment, which is the term that
Deirdre McCloskey and other economic
historians have used
for the past 200 years,
roughly the period of
industrialization where,
you know, things went from being
pretty flat for a thousand years
or more to getting better
and better.
Gail, one of the kind
of
figure the you know, the spirit
animal of your book is Julian
Simon. Can you explain who
he is and why he's so
important to the to the project
here?
Well, Julian Simon actually
was this obscure kind of economist
and was teaching at university.
And there was a book
that was published in 1968 by
Stanford biologist Paul
Ehrlich, and it the title
was "The Population
Bomb." And he makes these claims
about, "look, we're facing this
extinction because there are too
many people." And Julian actually
said that he when he originally
read the book, he thought, well,
this this theory seems
to be reasonable.
But as he began to kind of check
the facts, what he discovered,
he said, to his surprise, is that as
population increased, all these
resources became even more abundant.
So he and Ehrlich
began to have this quite
public dispute about what was
going to happen in the future, what
is that relationship between
population resources?
And it finally ended up in a
bet.
And Julian said,
Look, pick any nonrenewable
resource for any period over a year
and I'll bet you that it's going to
become more abundant.
In other words, the price is going
to go to fall, adjusted for
inflation.
And so early picks
five metals: copper,
chromium, nickel, tin and tungsten.
And they, they had this bet for a
ten year period from 1980 to
1990.